[Music]
hey kirk
it's been a while holy [ __ ]
barely recognize you see you haven't
changed
not a single girl you know me
i'm old-fashioned like that slow and
steady wins the race huh
so come on sit down i'll spill you the
deets
start talking all right all right listen
job's simple i've got a van standing not
far from here
brimming with merch worth fat digits
driving to the border tomorrow but a lot
of things could happen before then
you feel me specifics kirk what's in the
van
militech implants experimental series
[ __ ] you can't get on the street
straight out of some lab in shanghai
who does it belong to jesus
cares once we take it it's ours
so can i count on you or not
sounds too good to be true
oh [ __ ] it it's worth a shot at least
count me in oh it's true all right
anyways send you the cohorts see you at
the spot
[Applause]
later
hey back off into our bus here
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey hey v over here
what's up kirk happy to see you too but
how about let's not broadcast it
right right sorry no need for a scene
okay see that garage right there fans
inside
go in grab the tech get out we split it
50 50. clear
okay and i go head on a swivel
right
i'll clear my ass
this is the road of fire
oh [ __ ]
he got hit
wheels are there
what the the [ __ ] is this
clothes cheap knockoffs too
had real great intel that kirk like
always actually
but hey could strike out on your own
open up a stand in kabuki or maybe
implants [ __ ] militech wear
i'ma shove these duds right up his ass
[ __ ] now firefight
okay
nice speech remind me not to invite you
to my funeral
how about him gonna tell anyone to
scrape them up and put him under
i want to tell